let's go next to our caller from the
seven-one-seven area code who's calling
today from seven one seven hello David
Neiman Lukas I'm a college student here
in Pennsylvania
Brad I was curious your reaction to peak
Buddha says taking the early lead with
62% of the results given in Iowa and if
you had any thoughts on his progress
when he when he was doing his speech to
the news he kept emphasizing proud his
team of four people came from nowhere
and people said he wouldn't be able to
do a thing because it was just a mayor
and how you feel is on his progress so
far well even with now you know we're
beyond 62% Budaj edge still is doing
very well I I don't think that much of
it in terms of like I don't find his
campaign very interesting he's much too
centrist for my tastes
I I'm interested in the strategy for the
DNC establishment because Pete Buddha
judge did well in Iowa and Joe Biden did
not do well despite what the polls said
going in I'm curious to see whether the
establishment shifts that support away
from Biden and to Pete or potentially
even to Michael Bloomberg because
Bloomberg has almost unlimited spending
capacity and now potentially will be
participating in upcoming debates
because of the rule changes so my view
on Pete you know I think his his view on
healthcare is wacky and you know I think
his background as a consultant does not
make him uniquely well-suited to be
president and you know claiming victory
before any votes were counted was really
weird and whatever you know none of that
my view and none of that has changed but
I'm interested to see whether the DNC
gets behind him and abandons Biden right
and one more thing I on you could be
like there was such a divide between age
ranges and who they supported in America
I believe it said that people over 65
were hardcore supporting Joe and then
people are
my age and the 20s were more so
supporting Bernie and if you have any
advice or anything how do people in
their 20s actually get out to the polls
because I know we need at turn out to
actually make a difference in defeat
Trump yeah I don't have the silver
bullet every election it's always this
discussion is hey you know what X can
that it is doing so well among young
voters but young voters are far less
likely to actually go out and vote how
do we mobilize them and if if I had
figured that out I'd probably be a
political consultant at this point
because that's a tough nut to crack so I
don't I don't have any particular
insight I really appreciate the phone
call Lucas and I hope to hear from you
again